this is the first time since the 1950s
we've been operating up here in an ice
capable vessel
this navy video about a new canadian
arctic ship's first deployment
circumnavigating north america showcased
in a flurry of recent tweets from the
defense minister highlighting that
canadians are taking part in half a
dozen different planned exercises in the
north including noble defender this week
norad's arctic air defense operation
with 250 canadians and 100 americans
launching from variety of bases in the
north
intercepting aircraft that will be
replicating both adversary aircraft and
cruise missile threats the deputy
commander says the exercise sends a
message to russia we're watching them 24
hours seven days a week and we are so
well equipped trained and integrated
that any type of attack would be futile
there's no accident that all of these
are coming at the same time that the
conflict of course is raging across
ukraine defense minister anita anand is
planning a visit to the arctic herself
in the coming months focused on security
as we look at the north and our
relatively low population density up
there
it's not inconceivable that our
sovereignty may be challenged russia has
been reactivating cold war bases and
recently applied to the un for a vast
extension to its claim on the
continental shelf certainly now with the
aggressive activity of russia it makes
us rethink then these other processes
that
were
based but perhaps won't be in the future
experts say the crisis also highlights
canada's sluggish contributions to norad
badly in need of modernization we are
the ones who have talked the most about
modernizing and bringing up to date our
northern capabilities and probably have
done the least out of all of the other
arctic states canada will be at the
table in the short term with a robust
package to modernize norad
modernizing norad is in onan's mandate
letter defense watchers say they'll have
to see action to believe it on a
long-standing promise abigail beeman
global news ottawa